ukrainian officials have tried to tamp
down washington's assessment that an
invasion could be imminent
for a sense of conditions on the ground
and the movements along the border we go
to mts tayyib in the ukrainian capital
of chief mtios good morning
jeff good morning with the threat of a
russian-led war only growing it's a race
against time to find a diplomatic
solution to this crisis as ukrainian
forces brace
for the worst
never has patrolling this perimeter been
so fraught with peril
the narrow sliver of territory separates
ukraine from belarus
and it's up to these ukrainian border
forces to keep a close eye on their
nation's northern front
it's almost
eerily quiet here but there in belarus
russian and belarusian forces are
holding some of the largest military
exercises since the cold war
margarita versinina is the commander in
charge
there are so many russian troops they
have so many weapons
will you be able to defend yourselves uh
uh we are prepared for any threat she
says
russia's live fire military exercises in
belarus is being seen as a prelude to
war
a war which could cost tens of thousands
of lives and displace millions as
president biden urges all americans in
ukraine to leave with the state
department worrying too few are doing so
it's a difficult decision says brian
best the u.s citizen lives in keeve with
his ukrainian wife and two children
have you made any calculations any sort
of plans contingency plans it's it's
really difficult to plan for
where would i go
this is this is my home you know i i i i
suppose that if
if bullets were flying uh in in kiev
yeah i would i would uh get in our car
and we would we would find the closest
border and try to exit
but until then i think we'd stay here as
long as we can
now russia adamantly denies it has any
plans to invade ukraine accusing the
west of spreading lies as u.s
intelligence officials warn russian
military leaders have been told to be
prepared to strike by as early as next
week michelle
mts thank you